la chance il faut savoir qu'elle est
partout il faut savoir l'attraper il
sait il faut savoir l'attirer exactement
et puis il y a des personnes aussi qui
peuvent être un petit peu un
porte-bonheur pour certaines autres
personnes tu sais que moi il y a des
chroniqueurs que je prends pas parce que
je pense qu'il y a quoi alors je les
adore ah bon ah c'est ça il y a des
potes que j'aimerais faire travailler
les boules c'est pas ça tu vois la seule
fois grave quoi
de bonheur non
invité
un grand amoureux
alors donc il y a des mecs qui portent
la soupe quoi alors par contre
Jean-Marie lui on peut dire que
qu'est-ce qui va m'arriver
parce que c'est votre vie a changé un
petit peu grâce à TPMP et je crois que
vous êtes dans quelque chose qui est un
renouveau complet absolument important
alors il faut savoir que pour vous il y
a des choses qui vont se passer de façon
positive alors je vois un film combien à
peu près à zéro ou deux non moi ce que
je vois c'est plutôt quelque chose
qui revient à des anciennes amours comme
le cinéma ou quelque chose comme ça
d'accord
vous pourriez de contacter dans peu de
temps pour faire quelque chose aussi au
cinéma d'accord
ça provoque aussi
nous on appelle ça l'effet agrégore
c'est quoi c'est la Constitution au nom
de positive qu'on fait au dessus de soi
plus on pense que on a du positif qui va
nous arriver et plus on pense que la
chance va venir à nous plus c'est
égrégore grandit et devient important et
vous portez alors ce qui est marrant
c'est que c'est exactement la même chose
pour la poisse
il a enchaîné les yeux les seins on va
regarder ça avec Benjamin tout à l'heure
alors les grands gagnants pour moi
aujourd'hui c'est les signes de la
balance
pourquoi comme ça en ce moment il y a le
chalet va vous expliquer pourquoi
la lune qui fait le tour du zodiaque et
là pendant cette journée du vendredi 13
et pendant quelques heures après elle va
stimuler un petit peu tous les signes de
la balance donc ça veut dire que si vous
voulez jouer au loto
loto la chanson d'amour aussi donc pour
les rencontres pour
un petit peu avant la Saint-Valentin
donc je pense que là c'est c'est
intéressant de déjà programmer certaines
choses et moi je vous donne un conseil
et là c'est mon conseil toujours être
célibataire pour la Saint Valentin
[Applaudissements]
de fois j'ai rompu le 12
13 je me suis dit le 13 c'est trop
voyant le 12
tu commences à t'embrouiller le disque
tu commences à t'embrouiller
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
depuis des années les grands gagnants du
Loto par exemple il y en a eu 6 c'est
des signes du poisson c'est moi
qui ont plus de chance il y a eu 6
gagnants six gros gagnants du Loto ils
étaient tous du signe du Poisson
et dites moi le Capricorne 22 décembre
ça donne quoi
le Capricorne
alors faites attention parce que si vous
êtes quand même vous allez gonfler
je crois que les Capricorne le
Capricorne c'est plus sur tout ce qui
est matériel sur ce qui est financier
sur ce qui investissement
lui il va plus sur tout ce qui est
affectif et il a beaucoup de chance en
amour généralement
les taureau alors le taureau il faut
savoir que le taureau par exemple la
planète maîtresse qui régit le son du
taureau c'est Vénus Vénus c'est l'amour
moi je suis très mignon
[Rires]
alors j'explique tout ça effectivement
dans le livre on peut retrouver tous les
choses
en ce moment pourquoi parce que il y a
une planète qui s'appelle Jupiter qui
est la planète de la chance qui est dans
le signe du bélier jusqu'au mois de mai
à peu près donc il y a des péchés
la roue de la fortune
[Applaudissements]
le bâton change de main
[Rires]
les choses vont évoluer et vont tourner
d'une façon très positive pour lui et
moi je vois quelque chose qui est en
négociation ou qui va être en
négociation dans les jours à venir très
important qui peut faire changer sa
carrière
c'est tout ce qui est
moto
scooter
ça je me suis pété la jambe
elle est d'accord quand on lui dit ça il
y a pas l'argent il y a l'accident
il est vraiment est-ce qu'il y aura
vraiment les deux cette fois-ci parce
que un moment ça suffit
une seule qu'est-ce qu'il y a
[Rires]
merde la mort
l'étoile l'étoile alors l'étoile ça fait
partie des meilleurs cartes du Tarot de
Marseille
c'est pas des toiles de David
pour vous ça représente tout ce qui est
artistique et médiatique donc ça veut
dire qu'il y a une évolution sur le plan
des médias avec une nouvelle émission
qui va arriver bientôt
Annabelle elle avait déjà dit
mais il y a une nouvelle émission qui
arrive avec un nouveau concept un
nouveau concept est quelque chose de
nouveau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la femme élastique
j'ai peur
apparemment tu vas transformer un ballon
dirigeable
c'est quoi alors c'est la carte de la
tempérance
tout passe d'un côté et de l'autre c'est
à dire que c'est les vases communicants
donc il y a pas grand chose qui se passe
à part que il y a des choses qui
évoluent mais qui retombe à zéro et de 0
qui repartent
la deuxième chance
[Applaudissements]
le tirage que je suis en train de faire
là c'est de tirage qu'on appelle le
tirage de la chance j'explique un peu
plus en détail dans le livre bien sûr
parce que là je peux pas te donner
une seule une seule
Jean-Marie c'est quelqu'un que je
ressens comme très
spirituels
il y a quelque chose blanche
vous avez perdu une couille
allez directement c'est la meilleure du
jeu c'est pas vrai c'est la carte du
monde du monde alors le monde
ça veut dire que les projets dont on a
parlé tout à l'heure peuvent avoir un
rapport aussi avec l'étranger ah tu vas
dire qu'il y a des choses
négocier avec des sociétés étrangères ou
des institutions ou des boîtes de
production étrangères au niveau du
continue
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est simplement la Renaissance parce
que quand on regarde bien
sur la carte il y a comme des épis de
blé donc c'est le cycle de la vie et du
recommencement donc ça veut dire que par
contre vous allez transformer totalement
votre vie sur quelque chose de
totalement nouveau
j'ai l'impression que depuis quelques
mois il y a plein de choses qui
s'arrêtent brutalement dans votre vie le
boulot bientôt
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
pour faire des choses totalement
différentes par contre moi je vois une
rencontre sentimentale mais avec
quelqu'un d'un opposé de des personnes
que vous aimiez sur le plan jeune donc
quelqu'un de très différent très
différent dans la façon d'être dans la
façon de se mouvoir dans la façon de
communiquer
c'est quelqu'un vous connaissez pas du
tout et ça sera un concours de
circonstances
il est 19h30
merci beaucoup merci
inquiétez pas on fait comme ça
alors pourquoi tu fais des petits sauts
de Cabris
en plus donc merci
[Rires]
l'étoile alors c'est pareil
des choses nouvelles des choses qui vont
vous amener sur la réflexion sur la
façon d'être et sur la façon d'avancer
aussi dans les médias peut-être donner
une autre image ou quelque chose de
différent parce que peut-être que vous
est souffrez entre guillemets peut-être
d'une image un peu lisse et vous auriez
envie de faire passer autre chose vous
pouvez m'appeler appelle-moi si tu veux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
en train de t'embrasser
une tierce personne
non c'est le chariot toi c'est à dire
que tu vas aller chez Carrefour
que vous bougez beaucoup vous vous
déplacez vous pouvez aller à l'étranger
souvent à l'étranger partir déplacer
c'est et puis il y a rien un projet
aussi de montrer quelque chose de
personnel il veut monter doit monter une
armoire ce weekend
comme si vous étiez un peu le boss ou le
patron de cette chose là en plus
intéressant où vous allez chapeauté
diriger tout ça avec un déplacement avec
beaucoup de déplacements des choix des
placements
[Rires]
en tout cas le vendredi 13 porte chance
à pas mal de personnes aujourd'hui c'est
quand même possible on a le temps
mais avec toi vas-y
j'aime bien parce que ça passe tout le
temps
[Rires]
un peu là je vois une seringue vous avez
fait votre appel
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
de prendre une retraite entre guillemets
mes retraites spirituelles c'est à dire
le besoin de se connecter à la
spiritualité un petit peu comme
Jean-Marie donc
aller ensemble
mais on irait très bien il y a que elle
qui est pas d'accord
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
une formation comme si vous alliez vous
former à quelque chose de nouveau d'être
infirmière
aujourd'hui et qui a un attrait qu'un
rapport aussi avec la spiritualité et
avec tout ce qui touche lesotérisme vous
êtes attiré par lesotérisme pas du tout
les hôtels
là ça va bouger ça va changer en vous ça
va se transformer en quelque chose qui
va vous amener à aller vers ce terrain
là je pense que c'est les gens qui vous
entourent qui sont un petit peu de comme
ça qui vont les amener sur ce terrain là
très bien
donc beaucoup de sensibilité aussi chez
le cancer donc la lune qui régit le
cancer
[Rires]
c'est à dire
c'est pas ouf
tu as une relation en ce moment ouais
c'est fini c'est fini
[Rires]
c'est pas mal parce que regarde ce que
c'est et vu nos projets c'est pas mal la
roue de la fortune
alors par contre c'est quelqu'un qui est
très attiré par l'argent
[Rires]
l'argent est capital est important
carrément après on aura une donnée au
moins
[Rires]
c'est quelqu'un qui cherche
même il sait pas voilà oui et c'est
l'impératrice ça veut dire que ça y est
il va devenir Sissi
[Applaudissements]
sa transition va être faite
l'impératrice c'est tout ce qui
représente le besoin de communiquer le
besoin de s'exprimer le besoin
d'extérioriser des choses alors
peut-être qu'il a eu une phase peut-être
dans ce moment en France ou plus jeune
ou il communiquait difficilement ou un
peu renfermé j'allais voir
l'orthophoniste
c'est quelque chose qui vous libère
et qui vous permet en tout cas de
d'extérioriser
tu étais engoncé
donc il y a beaucoup de projets dans
tout ce qu'on a fait tant que ça va être
une année 2023 très chanceuse pour eux
c'est vrai ouais
alors Ilona est-ce qu'on peut faire
tirer
je vais te le dire après
faire mariage
avec mon fils
alors là Ilona elle a tiré le regarde
mais c'est pas le diable dans le sens
mauvais du terme c'est le mec on parle
du vendredi 13
c'est tout ce qui est en rapport avec
les énergies et le magnétisme d'accord
voilà donc ça veut dire qu'il peut y
avoir un besoin de développer des
énergies parce qu'il peut y avoir des
baisses d'énergie à certains moments où
les complications sur les énergies à
gérer ces énergies donc là ça veut dire
qu'il faut travailler sur ces énergies
développer ses énergies et malgré tout
je pense que c'est quelqu'un qui a une
certaine charisme certaines formes de
magnétisme
qui rayonne quoi c'est vrai que tu
rayonne merci merci ma chérie
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
la roue de la fortune
[Applaudissements]
tout ce qui est en rapport avec l'argent
ça se passe bien non la chance non non
beaucoup de chance
encore pour l'année 2023 des nouveaux
projets des nouvelles choses qui se
mettent en place un virage et un
tournant aussi en cours de l'année pour
s'orienter aussi vers des nouvelles
émissions ou des nouveaux concepts
encore plus d'oseille quoi
quand même